bonjour nouveau numéro du 7 8 était
avant de se retrouver sur le plateau la
rédaction continue jusqu'au 3 septembre
à parcourir le département pour vous
proposer des activités à faire durant
les vacances en seconde partie de ce
magazine je vous parlerai de cette serre
aux papillons où l'on trouve près de 700
espèces c'est à la queue-lez-yvelines
mais tout de suite on retrouve catherine
plateau avec sylvie la luna est la
directrice divine tourisme
et voilà on se retrouve sur le golf de
la base de loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines avec mon invité sylvie l'anah
bonjour bon c'est la directrice divine
tourisme avec vous on va faire un peu un
point pas sur toutes les sorties dans
les yvelines pour cet été parce qu'il y
en a beaucoup mais vous avez fait votre
petite sélection et si on se trouve ici
dans un univers verdoyant du golfe c'est
pas par hasard expliquez-nous ça oui
c'est pas par hasard parce que le
département des yvelines est le plus
golfique des départements de france donc
c'est pas rien il ya 25 cols sur le
département et donc il ya un certain
nombre de golf qui sont des exclusives
golfe y en a à feucherolles 1 avec moins
en rochefort en yvelines qui pratiquent
des tarifs spécifiques pour l'été donc
on peut aller à tarifs très réduits pour
jouer au golf et puis pour ceux qui ont
besoin un petit peu d'initiation qui ne
savent pas trop s'ils ont envie d'en
faire ou pas il ya des initiations
gratuites qui sont au golf de
rochechouart en yvelines donc bonne idée
pour démarrer un petit peu une pratique
sportive qui finalement est accessible à
beaucoup de noms mais parce qu'on dit
que c'est souvent cher le golfe et bah
finalement les tarifs pour tout l'été
c'est au tour de entre 250 et 300 euros
pour jouer tout l'été dans un golf quand
on veut d'accord dans leurs dogmes des
yvelines absolument tout à fait alors on
va quitter le golf on va aller du côté
de la ferme de gally ça c'est à saint
cyr l'école et on peut faire plein de
choses à la ferme de gally on peut faire
des choses en famille notamment alors ça
c'est bien parce que bon le golf c'est
pas forcément familier à la ferme de
gally il ya beaucoup de ça des golfs à y
aller avec ses enfants aussi oui alors
voilà il ya des labyrinthes à la ferme
de gally alors c'est assez ludique on a
des labyrinthes différents est
labyrinthe circulaire on peut venir pour
les enfants de plus de 7 ans dont très
très ludique il ya un autre labyrinthe
qui est un labyrinthe pour les plus
petits toujours labyrinthe de maïs parce
que
agali c'est un labyrinthe de maïs
notamment et puis c'est plus petits
peuvent découvrir les animaux qui
étaient dans la ferme de louis xiv à
l'époque et puis un labyrinthe de fleurs
le petit labyrinthe de fleurs seront
pour les petits parce que je dis le
petit l'asie remarque de flins où on
doit chercher la coquille de nono
l'escarbot
sakho qui cherche une aiguille dans une
botte de foin pas ça peut prouver la
coquille et on gagne quelque chose on
retrouve la callas rien on gagne la joie
d'avoir retrouvé la copine de joe que ça
c'est à la fin de dialyse mais pas la
faire gagner alors on va saint germain
en laye c'est la traditionnelle fête des
loges
la fête des loges à saint germain a été
inaugurée ya pas très longtemps donc
c'est une fête qui est important tant en
volume puisqu'elle représente 7 ha de
surface il ya 200 animations il ya le
train fantôme les autos tamponneuses la
galerie des glaces enfin toujours les
les activités classiques des défaites
mais il ya aussi la halle et des
cuisines oublier la gastronomie quand on
va dans les fêtes foraines on va rester
à saint germain en laye il ya beaucoup
d'hôtels particuliers à saint germain
alors forcément le devis droit à la
canton quand on déambule dans les rues
de saint germain le voit pas forcément
mais il ya effectivement puisque c'est
une ville moyenne il ya beaucoup
d'hôtels particuliers et il ya des
autres pour peut visiter cette oui alors
il ya un hôtel particulier qu'est
l'hôtel de noailles donc qu'ils se
trouvent effectivement dans saint
germain qu'on peut visiter côté jardin
si on le souhaite parce qu'il ya un
parcours commenté qui est réalisé par la
propriétaire françoise brissart et puis
également on peut le visiter à
l'intérieur ces visites vont avoir lieu
donc une grosse partie de l'été jusqu'au
22 août et puis ces visites se font
aussi à l'intérieur donc il ya un salon
de musique qui a accueilli jean chrétien
bach et mozart et on peut découvrir
toutes ces merveilles à l'occasion de la
visite de l'hôtel de noailles alors
c'est un auteur qui a été construit par
le duc de noailles on peut rappeler à
quelle période il a été construit alors
il était il a été construit entre 1662
19 et 1682 voit l'annoncé des visites à
faire du 11 juillet par tenu en juillet
jusqu'au 25 août john voilà on peut
faire ça alors si on n'aime pas être à
l'intérieur on peut être à l'extérieur
et on aime aussi beaucoup en donné dans
les yvelines et on peut randonner alors
là vous nous emmener loin loin au bout
du département dans le pays ou pas mais
c'est ça alors le pays où danet et
l'office du tourisme plus
particulièrement du pays où dan hay a
créé 28 circuits
circuit rando pédestre et vtt également
donc pour découvrir le coin qui est un
petit peu hors du temps si on peut dire
on peut aller le long des petites
rivières on peut découvrir la faune la
flore et tous tous ces espaces un peu
ruraux aussi qu'ils ont gardé des
regarder la tradition alors il ya des
circuits qui sont un peu pour tous les
niveaux il y en a 2 4 km et de 17 km
donc pour les néophytes mais aussi pour
ceux qui pratiquent plus régulièrement
donc ça l'un pour avoir toutes les
informations se renseigne auprès de
l'office de tourisme 2 ou dans ses
alentours le plus d'information on va
quitter la terre on va aller sur l'eau
là conflans sainte honorine parce
qu'évidemment c'est la ville des
bateliers et on va faire du bateau oui
les croisières plutôt oui alors à
conflans il ya tout un tas de croisière
qui ont été créés spécifiquement pour la
saison estivale donc des croisières
promenades avec commentaires les plus
classiques des croisières déjeuner pour
ceux qui apprécient aussi la gastronomie
qui veulent passer un peu plus de temps
sur le bateau et puis des journées à
bord alors là la journée à bord ça veut
dire que d'un bout de la journée à
l'autre on est sur le on est sur ce
bateau promenade donc on peut aller
visiter tous les sites impressionnistes
de chatou à auvers et le bateau chapelle
je sers qui est assez extraordinaire qui
n'existe que là tout à fait on part
maintenant à mantes la jolie ont visité
des remparts le des remparts à mantes la
jolie et oui des couples en dessous
alors mantes-la-jolie ses ennemis une
ville médiévale à l'origine donc
forcément les villes médiévales était
entourée de remparts donc l'office de
tourisme de menthe propose de faire une
promenade commentée au bord de ces de
ses remparts et explique comment à
l'époque du moyen-age
les villas était comment préserver grâce
à ses remparts et préserver de ces de
leurs agresseurs potentiels et puis on
découvre aussi évidemment tous les sites
un peu classique la collégiale
magnifique collégiale de menthe la tour
saint-martin et puis donc tout ce qui a
à voir amante les bords de seine qui
sont en forme hier qui ont inspiré les
peintres à apprécier donc un circuit de
3 km renseignements à l'office de
tourisme de mende ont fini avec deux
petites infos rapides alors on peut
devenir fauconnier oui on peut devenir
fauconnier ça se passe à l'espace aux
apprentis faut que vous ayez donc là on
apprend si on a alors il faut avoir plus
de 14 ans
et être accompagnés d'un adulte ne pas
avoir peur des rapaces ça c'est sûr ça
va sans dire on apprend à les nourrir on
voit un peu le tout le principe de la
dea des volières
la façon dont on les dres dont ils vont
voler dans les airs voilà on peut
devenir fauconnier d'un jour à l'espace
rambouillet est la dernière idée sortie
de l'été c'est les le haras des
bréviaires alors national des panthères
parce que voilà les yvelines capitale du
cheval a tenu mon rôle
en passe et des meilleures on est
capital de tout on est on est quand même
le département d'île de france où il ya
quand même le plus de choses à faire est
prêt et très proches les uns des autres
donc au haras des bréviaires on peut y
aller en famille par exemple on ne sait
une activité qui est ludique convivial
on voit un peu les étalons
spectacle d'aider des chevaux qu'ils
soient montés ou en liberté avec de la
musique on peut visiter les écuries la
sellerie royal voilà bien merci pour
toutes ces infos il est sorti pour le
département on a vu que c'était quand
même très très riches merci beaucoup
sylvie la mena on va mettre en parler de
lieu de l'audio guide vous en aviez déjà
parlé sur le plateau de tv fils ben si
vous ne savez pas ce que c'est je vous
propose de découvrir ce qu'elle
l'audioguide travers un sujet j'ai testé
de l'audioguide
bonjour à tous au programme comment
découvrir la vallée de chevreuse et ses
environs grâce à eux du guide en plein
air décidé aux petits et aux grands
curieux pour le découvrir nous allons
rejoindre géraldine de l'office du
tourisme de saint quentin en yvelines on
y va
vous avez déjà dû voir cet appareil dans
les musées mais sachez que vous vivez au
sein d'un riche patrimoine pour le
découvrir il suffit de suivre ce guide
de poche qui vous emmènera dans une
douzaine de destinations alors vous
pouvez récupérer le l'audio guide à
l'office de tourisme pendant les heures
les heures d'ouverture de l'office donc
du mardi au samedi de 10h30 à 18h donc
c'est très simple c'est une location la
journée 5 euros cet appareil se veut
ludique et à la portée de toute la
famille par exemple seriez vous capable
de répondre à cette question sur votre
droite dans le tableau de l'homme de la
nature morte représentants des pommes
l'artiste a glissé deux abréviation
lesquelles
cet audioguide a été créée à
l'initiative du parc naturel régional de
la vallée de chevreuse il ya maintenant
cinq en virginie le veau nous explique
pourquoi on a vendu à des centaines de
kilomètres de sentiers balisés on a
toute une connaissance sur les
patrimoines les monuments les sites
naturels le petit patrimoine caché et
toute cette information-là demandait
qu'à être valorisés sous une forme un
petit peu plus original et un peu plus
ludique que les classiques documents
papier cet appareil permet de profiter
des visites guidées à son propre rythme
muni d'un gps vous êtes assuré de
pouvoir visiter les châteaux et autres
monuments en forêt en ville ou au bord
de l'yvette laisse plus tranquille et
laventure n'est pas prête de s'arrêter
alors le les développements futurs pour
cet appareil là c'est évidemment de
basculer très vite sur la technologie
téléphonie mobile donc du coup va très
rapidement fait proposer toutes ces
balades la
téléchargeable via notre site internet
pour que les gens puissent quand ils ont
un appareil équipé de gps valeurs
directement de récupérer sur leurs
appareils
la sortie de cette application est
prévue pour la prochaine saison d'ici là
douze ballades sont toujours disponibles
dans les eaux de guide en plein air
au fait la réponse à la question et san
et au pea ce sont les initiales des
institutions qui a commandé cette heure
sonne pour syndicat d'agglomération
nouvelle et au pea pour établissement
public d'aménagement
maintenant vous savez ou alors profitez
de l'été et soyez curieux